jimmy carter called and he wants his
presidency back the white house is
reportedly worried about the strong
parallels that exist between joe biden
and former president carter as more
voters notice it's the 70s all over
again
americans are waking up to new record
high gas prices the nationwide average
is almost at five dollars a gallon
inflation is taking a massive bite out
of everyone's budget and the president's
approval rating keeps finding new lows
83 percent of americans say the economy
is poor or not so good under biden
while things are looking dire for joe
he's finding some support out there
i think what the president biden and the
administration did was really save this
economy when they came in with the covet
packages that put some money back in the
economy you know the interesting part
about this is the economy is really not
doing too bad at all i think it's time
for democrats starting taking credit for
the good things that are out there and
there is a lot of
you know what greg for some reason i
think there's a disconnect between what
that guy was saying
and the fact that americans are feeling
83 percent of them that the country is
certainly going in the bad direction and
they're not feeling good about the
economy he says what president biden has
done real was really to save the economy
they came in with a coveted package what
say well clearly this guy doesn't drive
or he doesn't do anything that he
doesn't know the crisis of things you
know it is it's kind of like the white
house response when
you know
sorry we really can't help you you know
as far as we can tell things are great
uh so it might be you it could be you
it's like the
white house is run like a telemarketing
firm it's like they call you when they
need your business
but they never pick up after you're
already paid and you got the package and
it's all broken and it takes you forever
i still love their strategy of you
coming up with impossible expectations
like it's not like we have a switch
to turn on the baby food uh
machine because there is one there's not
like there's a dial so i came up for
this that sets gas prices so i have some
new wins it's not like you can push a
button to end crime
it's not like you can wave your magic
wand to solve inflation but these are
all these things that they do to excuse
their failure all the other previous
presidents they didn't have buttons or
dials but they still got it done i've
had a button it brought them diet coke
that's right
all right dana you know there's no end
in sight this morning gas prices were up
again
but the democrats keep trying to paint a
rosy picture and the american people
kind of get it with the polling
yeah so i'm trying to think of something
that they could do in their current
situation i mean i know what i all the
things that we would say like we'll
obviously do more drill allow for more
drilling
relax the regulations etc so there's all
those things they could do but they're
not willing to do that and i was reading
in mark halperin's uh
wide world of news column that he does
and he writes these fake memos from ron
clayne to the president but it really
lays out a lot of truths and one of the
things that claine says to biden in this
fake memo is well if you think things
are bad now if we don't do things that
are more to the left your numbers will
go down even more because the only thing
holding you up right now is the far left
progressives who are holding out hope
that you'll do student loan relief or
something more on climate change etc so
i don't i just don't think that there's
anything communications wise they can do
that will solve this it's a policy
problem and i think everybody we always
as americans human beings you'd like to
compare to something in the past i
actually think the situation we're in
right now is much worse than the 70s you
know jesse one of the things they talk
about is you know putting more money
into the economy and that you know that
will save the
save all of us yeah spend more and
that'll help the dollar i look back at
what carter did in the 70s to get us out
of the energy crisis and it's like 10
times more than what biden did carter
actually put a pipeline through alaska
he introduced more nuclear power the
light water reactors he introduced more
domestic production tried to get us off
our dependence on foreign oil and went
green so
all of those things
are like actual substantial things you
could do as president joe biden has just
tinkered around the edges he wants to
blend a little more ethanol into the
gasoline which is going to just raise
food prices he's cancelling pipelines
he's he's actually making us more
dependent on foreign oil when he goes
and begs the saudis to pump more so
people like to say that jimmy carter is
the worst president of all time at least
carter was smart we had gingrich on the
show last night and he reminded me that
carter graduated from the naval academy
it was a nuclear
submarine guy he actually had a brain on
the shoulders and biden obviously
doesn't and it's sad that's his title
nuclear submarine guy
and also former president
you know chelsea the white house they
say is in a panic they're stressed what
should they do well first of all stop
thinking about yourself and actually
think about getting things done for the
american people i think that's the first
problem is they're concerned about how
they look second of all i think they've
got it completely wrong biden will be
remembered as being worse than jimmy
carter because they're talking about gas
prices and inflation and how things were
bad then and now but they're ignoring
the fact that carter's policies didn't
fast-track us into a new cold war and
push us into a place where we're closer
to a nuclear war now than since uh the
cuban missile crisis um carter didn't
denounce and reject half the country as
domestic terrorists carter didn't stick
the department of justice on parents who
are trying to fight for their children's
education the list goes on and on
i really wish the president united
states and the white house would really
focus on
actually doing the work for the american
people rather than thinking about
perceptions or politics or elections or
all these other things all right hi
everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want you
to do me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
fox you can get it all here on youtube
so subscribe right now